a quarter here in Brooklyn I Anil
Richard Jefferson Michael Grady with us
had a special guest it's KD Kevin Durant
joining us here courtside great to have
you here towards me a few times an NBA
Finals for clarabelle boys yeah I will
say this so we were checking the numbers
and I personally held you under your
career average your career average 27 I
held you to 25 and the the 20 games that
we play yeah I was actually surprised
you actually did a solid job to go
undefeated what did Kevin do against you
defensively though we also check those
no yeah I was below my career average
well you know 11 the length was a little
bit of a problem especially as I got
older Kevin you're gonna answer this for
the one millionth time
how're you feeling there's been fun
playing threes of the guys yeah okay
you're getting into that 303 action are
they allowed to foul you yet yeah
definitely
yeah they especially do your hat what
we've seen it by his performance out he
is a hack the good news is we don't have
to talk anything about this game right
now
so tell me what you know look you had
with your foot injury you had a
prolonged you know kind of timeout but
now you're a little bit older you're
you're more established what is it that
you kind of miss in that either you're
surprised or or you knew you were going
to miss tour this time sees it off mr.
woo
I'm just getting up every day you can't
one of the guys gonna practice when she
bounces there's been difficult get away
from the same but know about Nam less
out somebody for to go get back into
slavery things what about this
perspective what can you take away from
what you've seen as a spectator which is
a completely different view point from
where your mind normally is yeah I mean
I'm just looking at a game from the
different layers you're seeing you know
the landscape of the lead and definitely
just look at that our team is sin
without guys get better each and every
day you don't see it practice habits I'm
saying you know how do you transfer it
to the games different feel I guess but
knock around Jordan got hacked on the
inside when I look at Karis levert I'll
get Spencer Dinwiddie Joe Harris and
Jared Allen to the entire doesn't I
often say that when you add you and you
add Kyrie to this mix you have a lot of
firepower right is that something that
you're looking forward to or you already
mentally because I know you're two three
steps ahead are you already looking
mentally to how to incorporate that guys
make sure that they can keep their game
because we know you're going to do what
you do Kyrie is gonna do it but is
mentally are you already trying to think
about how to bring that group together
yeah most definitely you know you look
at line of switches and you know which
guys will play well with each other into
game lineups and a half lineup so all
that stuff I've been trying to figure
out what's best you know for myself
you'll have the guys like tears connelly
myself Toria special decals for
basketball is actually gonna make this
unpredictable zone looking forward to do
you see any similarities obvious had no
very different makeup with the shooting
what we had in Golden State
what do you see it in similar scenarios
with like how you were able to switch e4
across the line with multiple guys yeah
that's it will never be like you know we
had a on that team we had a couple of
guys that were sick sick sick 7nk
switching guard like you said you know
we got Tories planning for myself care
so I feel like every changeable weekend
you know cause that the havoc on defense
won't take us some time I did that can
have up a life adjustment living in
Brooklyn being a part of this community
what did you expect then what is the
reality been for you I expected a
fast-paced lifestyle you know New York
City everything's moving pretty fast
nobody sleeps so is a great sports town
Don I mean everybody's excited for the
game of basketball you know it was a
great place to
Brent's attacking the rim and a major
collision inside as Jackson takes the
hit for Memphis turnover Brooklyn
low-scoring game are you still moving
he's still moving this is your personal
call my personal call Cameron second
same thing you guys get in here Kevin
agrees with you more time jump shots
goes down for Tyus Jones it's a 3-ball
at Memphis leads at 28 to 24 so Kevin
you talk about the landscape of this
league right now and obviously it's
there's a little bit more clarity
guys are healthy that you guys are the
team to beat
obviously there's work to do you but
your level of confidence when you look
at the Eastern Conference in it even in
the NBA where you guys will stack up
healthy confidently we have some got
players on this team that could you know
definitely gotta have big night Sunday
night you had that talent on the floor
you give yourself a chance we got a good
coaching we got you know great bench you
know we're looking forward to just
bringing that all together it's gonna be
tough you know as we go on throughout
the summer and the season it just kind
of get that thing together so as always
a process how about the sea Karis levert
last night your tweet obviously caught
fire on the internet yeah your reaction
just watching Cara's between Richard you
should probably that's gonna count 51
points for your teammate yards the
birdie man that was a that was a
masterful game last night I think he
just put us on his back and all 14
points wanted to afford to get chiozza
having an impact once again for the
Brooklyn Nets last night in Boston
helping to lead a 7 all run here in the
second quarter tonight
Kady we appreciate a man great seeing
you
preciate him I feel good so all the best
Kevin Durant nice enough to join us for
a few minutes here ah yes we'll come